Hello and welcome to Let's Learn English with Anna.
I am Dr. Jill. but who are you?
Today we answer that question.
Who are you?
So let's go to Anna's treehouse.
She helps us answer the question.
Who are you?
Hi. welcome to my treehouse.
I am Anna.
And I am Max.
That is Max.
Max is a mailbox.
Anna. I have our question for today.
Thanks Max.
Who are you?
I am Anna.
I am Max.
Max. I'm not done yet.
Oh sorry.
Max. I'm done now.
And I am Max.
Nice song.
Okay friends. say the question after me.
Who are you?
Now. let's meet some new friends.
They answer today's question too.
I am Zenitsu.
I am Ana Avery.
Hi. I am Alexa.
How many friends do you see?
One. two. three.
That's right. three friends.
Okay. now let's play a game with our friends.
They say their names.
You listen.
Are you ready?
Here they are.
Find the names with the letter A.
I am Zenitsu.
I am Ana Avery.
Hi. I am Alexa.
That's right.
Alexa and Anna have the letter A.
Good job.
Now. let's go back to Anna's treehouse.
She talks about other words with the letter A.
Let's go.
Who are you?
I am Anna.
Anna starts with an A.
But the letter A has many sounds.
A. Ape.
A. Apple.
A. Anna.
Anna ate an apple.
Who are you?
I am Max.
You are Anna.
Who are you?
Who am I?
I need to walk.
Who?
Who are you?
You are an owl.
One owl.
Two owls.
Three owls.
I love owls.
And I love to walk.
Anna. it's time to go.
Thanks. Max.
Come back again. though.
Goodbye.
Now. you try it.
Ask your family and friends.
Who are you?
How do they answer?
I am Zenitsu.
I am Ana Avery.
Hi. I am Alexa.
See you next time on Let's Learn English with Anna.
Anna. I am Anna.
I am Anna.